tell me about what you
fright fest I'm promoting the zombie
times people call me zombie eight I've
been publishing the world's on who
zombie newspaper for seven years we've
got 13,000 people that subscribe at the
moment and we promote big releases but
also independent releases zombie walks
and films that need extras and makeup
artists and just so the current issue
with a zombie x has got things on
outpost to but also somebody
self-published a graphic novel called
zombies versus clowns and it's eight
pages and there's a couple of bands that
have done zombie tracks that we promote
as well so all levels of zombie stuff we
come down here every couple of years
just try and get people to sign up to
the newsletter hand out some flyers but
like I said there's 13,000 people that
actually read our stuff at the moment
and anything at all I mean one of the
big things we try and do is if anyone's
making a zombie film we get them extras
makeup artists sometimes financial
supports are kind of in indy gogo sites
and stuff like that but anything
zombie-related we do actually try and
promote why are zombies white so
appealing to me um he's a while ago is
asked the question which was simply why
zombies and I think it's because when
people watch zombie films it's a
conquerable evil if you're in a world
will film and you make a were wolf
you're dead Michael Myers Freddie anyone
like that but in a zombie film and I
think something that Shaun of the Dead
actually captured was you probably would
get a cricket bat and attempt to have a
go and it's it's a really accessible
genre as well loads of people can make a
decent low-budget zombie film there's
one that came out last year called dead
Genesis which is a really really
depressing film but it had no budget and
did affect beautiful emotionally when
they saw it so it's kind of if you are
making a were wolf film the makeup would
have to be you know exceptional serial
killer films really need something
significant and stand out but zombie
films you can get away with a lot and
still produce something that's
accessible and you know
I talking about makeup tell me about
what's going on here today because
you're looking mighty bloody my I say
tell me about your makeup now the outfit
is a family heirloom it's a dinner
jacket it's over 60 years old and my dad
wore it on stage and I've actually worn
it onstage and then it started falling
apart so I've been wearing this Ravel
eight years comparing zombie events the
shirt with bullet holes and inside out
black t-shirt and whenever i do makeup I
just wiped my hands on my shirt so it
keeps getting more and more messy and
the zombie makeup is actually young it's
very accessible because I've done loads
but and I've got a little Mark's and
Spencer sandwich bag with latex a bruise
wheel two different types of blood and
you can just do it in front of a toilet
mirror rather than sitting there for
half an hour and be pampered like some
strangely sinister victim of a beauty
parlor now if anyone's starting out and
think you know I like what that guy's
got going on fancy coming to event like
this dressing up as a zombie too what
are you tips for them always mess up
your clothing as much as possible
because there's nothing worse than
saying somebody really gory really
horribly made up but they're wearing a
pristine lab coat on the quick plug
front on terror for fun Tara then the
number for fun calm there are three
downloadable makeup guides one written
by me one written by a friend and one
written by Stewart conran who did the
makeup for Shaun of the Dead and it is
just we're trying to make it really
accessible but don't don't go overboard
i mean i started do it i've done sir
I'll do as a living of a makeup artist
for the NHS so I do actually do
medically accurate makeup
but go on Amazon get a couple of books
have a bit of a go my wife got really
fed up with being coated in latex and
wax and whatever but it just you know it
gives you something to do and you know
you get better and better and more
popular at Halloween and what got you
into zombies in the first place and I've
always liked the films and then a friend
a few years ago got a campsite I wanted
an activity for her 30th birthday and I
like zombies and she liked the 70s so we
kind of did just there was about 40
friends together and it ended up being a
bit kind of zombie s game of tic and if
it samba take to you you know etc but it
just grew from there we've done kind of
we've done it 11 zombie events over
seven years now and we do the UK
festival of zombie culture and the more
reason to be able to dress up and be
more zombified because it's not
pretentious it's not like vampires you
crushed velvet and you know serial
killers of dangerous weapons he had a
part of people who want to dress up as
on these shamble about half a dozen of
you is great I mean few years ago
Leicester Square there was 700 people
for the zombie diaries when that was
released as part of fright fest so it is
actually just a really nice thing you
know get together and you get all manner
of zombies greens on these white zombies
running about contact lens on these it's
just a really what's your favorite type
of zombie slow and simple because i
think the fast zombies you just screwed
end of you know i'm not just fit as it
should be you know i do enjoy a drink at
the weekend I just be zombie fodder so I
don't like to think of myself being just
on before they're so slow zombies I do
like and with zombie films the secret of
success is the more descriptive words
you put in front of it the better so if
you've got four Dead Snow you have nazi
zombies which is good the zombie Lake
you had underwater nazi zombies which
you know is even better so the more
things you can put in front of the word
zombie
you know australian air munching
vegetarian zombies you know it just it
intrigues people more what would you do
if faced with a zombie run now a lot of
people one thing that master is a vital
piece of equipment for surviving the
zombie apocalypse and it's chocolate
raisins because some people get old have
a cricket batter and I've gone or
whatever but chocolate raisins you've
got energy if you've got kids you've got
a bribe and it'll prevent you from being
constipated and they taste really nice
as well so loads of people think about
the combat side but I like to think
about the non constipated running away
side I thought where you were going with
the chocolate raisins was actually you
know to throw them on the floor and
distract the zombie so that they're not
kind of realizing that your food but
that would be a waste of chocolate
raisins something weird actually magnet
and they are quite nice there's a
chocolate raisins I always have some in
the house as well so when people say I'd
have a gun you know it's not that
realistic but you can go down the road
you can get chocolate raisins you can
survive if you I like to think of you
now maybe it's having a whole room or at
least a whole cupboard at home stuffed
with chocolate raisins unfortunately I
eat them all wet as soon as we get them
in the house but if it did look like we
were actually threatened with the
profits on the apocalypse i would start
hoarding them and eating them at the
same time but they are nice as well you
see so that's a top tip thank you very
much that i'm sure you'll save lots of
lives when the zombie apocalypse comes
thank you thanks very much
you